why were you in prison chris hemsworth
research the question that you start the
show
now it's research I did a movie about a
guy it was research I mean for research
Audra Tom's be so hungry why do you have
a story to tell because I I'm so taken
I'm trying to listen to Kevin and a
couple of stories back UKIP's it was the
story about I don't even know what the
story was like you kept saying meals
bills so what is that abby's deer both
beers field ears ears alright so that
was about years okay that's a few and
then just not when you're talking about
playing a prison
yeah you said and today I can't imitate
it it'll go bad no I can't it's like
I'll try I'm gonna try but it's gonna be
a big goal for the class and you can try
your Celtic and this day this gay stands
up and I'm thinking where you must see a
gay person stood oh no no but not guy I
found got that it was a guy a guy yeah
one vote away maybe it is presently yeah
I'd like to play a good gag hand and the
present had quite a good shirt I just
have a routine about you looking at me
to be the boss it is he saying out
I don't know stalker but like this it
attempted model you get a lesser
sentence then you get from model but you
stole thrive it just because you weren't
very good actor and my opinion should
get double the sentence for me an ass of
it right and loss these mantras pointing
over attempted models when I watch you
me this a strange so what I just said
artist if you just watch models tail
Wakeman murders look did you hurt her no
I didn't get that nice like muchos Dom I
don't know feet you all there why are
you in prison Chris
well they go to prison so now it's
researching a film and we had to go in
and basically see what the inside of the
prison look like and speak with
prisoners who are willing to talk to us
and um and I walked in and I remember
thinking and I had but ponytail long
blonde hair and I had a hat on and the
wardens Lilly knows where this is going
let's expect the night
and the warden said you can't wear your
hat and so on and I said okay no worries
I thought they're gonna even know
who I am then a thong I they don't get
Thor in here they're not gonna watch
movies and I've never been to prison so
assume that and the moment I started
walking through the cells and it's like
eight block of this thing and it's all
just kind of that you know cell upon
cell and so on and I just start getting
heckled and it's like you're Thor's here
man no Thor you're thorgy thor where the
wizard hammer man charlie like blend in
and you know research and just getting
heckled left and right about you know
come spend some time in my shell baby
you'll do yeah
anyways that was idle it wasn't a whole
of research more just coming
Lily can you understand anything I know
I got something about balls beating
that's takes time can I follow up just
go nice really had a good timing it just
goes shape